winterliche stille im skigebiet rund um
den tiroler berg ort ist wo sonst
tausende wintersportler die pisten
bevölkerung herrscht in diesem jahr
tote hose und doch bereitet man alles
für den großen ansturm vor
normalerweise werden jetzt zur eröffnung
heute mindestens 15.000 leute im
skigebiet und zu sein mal alleine da
muss ein überall bei die vorbereitungen
aber für wen wissen wir noch nicht hier
auf dem dorfplatz von ist bereit sich
ein après ski lokal ans andere
in den vergangenen jahren wurden für den
ski openings bis zu 15.000 touristen
hier begrüßt die dann hier auf dem
dorfplatz feierten etwas weiter weg
wurden auch riesige konzerte mit mariah
carey veranstaltet davon dieses jahr
keine spur
die hotels verrammelt für die
grundversorgung gibt es lediglich zwei
supermärkte selbst die bäckerei hat
geschlossen und nur ein einziger automat
spendet noch tröstende hüttengaudi likör
fünf euro allerdings hinter den kulissen
herrscht große betriebsamkeit hotels
machen ausbesserungsarbeiten und auch
die pisten werden selbstverständlich
gespuert alle sind bereit für den tag
ist von dem allerdings keiner weiß wann
er wirklich kommt
die region ist von den wintersportlern
abhängig ohne touristen keine einnahmen
aber nur einheimische können derzeit in
den schnee
jetzt und ich habe auch meinen aber dass
sich die wintersportsaison noch
entwickeln wird steht derzeit in den
sternen
österreich will seinen aktuell harten
lockdown möglicherweise noch mitte
dezember lockern und die skigebiete
wieder öffnen
die vorbereitungen für den
touristenansturm laufen wir seien
eigentlich vor dem vorbereiten wir
wissen zwar noch nicht wann skigebiet
aufgeht oder für webers herrichten aber
wir möchten einfach sollte es losgehen
gerichtet sein während man sich in ihr
spiel auf die neue saison vorbereitet
geht in deutschland die angst vor einem
neuen anstieg der infektionszahlen um
schließlich war es der tiroler berg ort
ist gilt der mit seiner après ski partys
zum symbol für unverantwortliche corona
politik wurde
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren